Hi.
I'm Hadley Wickham,
Chief Scientist at Posit
and for the purpose
of this video,
the chief maintainer
of the purrr package.
So what is the purrr package?
It's kind of hard to describe
what purrr is to be honest
but to put it into
words, I think
I've got a pretty good sense of like,
what function feels like a purrr
function to me.
But I think the
best way to think
of it is as a toolkit for
supporting, like, functional
programming.
What is functional programming?
That's also kind of hard to explain.
The chief advantage is it
gives you a bunch of tools
for operating on vectors or
pairs of vectors or triplets,
et cetera, of vectors where you
work on each individual element
of the vector in isolation.
And that allows you to apply
a function, to do something
to each element knowing
that there's no way
that the other elements
are going to affect
the computation at all.
So many of the functions of purrr
are alternatives to for loops.
For loops by any
means, like, not a bad thing.
You should never be embarrassed
or ashamed of using a for loop.
For loops are great because
they're very, very concrete
very obvious what you're doing
because you're doing, like, take
this element and do this to
it, take that element, do that,
and you can very easily think
about, like, stepping through that.
So the functions of purrr,
particularly the map functions
are kind of a step up in abstraction.
And that step up is, it's a challenge.
But I think there's some
good reasons to do it.
And the first one is it
makes it easy to avoid
or ensures that you
avoid some performance
bottlenecks with loops.
Now for loops themselves are
not slow, but if in your for loop
it's easy to get to accidentally
repeatedly modify or repeatedly
extend it, then can be slow,
although changes in the latest
versions of R have made that
much less bad than it
has been in the past.
So performance, it's
a little bit useful.
I think one big advantage
of switching to purrr
is that you can also
switch to, oops not future, but the furrr package.
So the furrr package has exactly
the same syntax as purrr,
but it spreads a computation
across multiple points.
So purrr, because it guarantees
that all of the computations
are independent
much, much easier
to share that work
across multiple calls.
The other thing, particularly
in this latest version of purrr
is that it gives you a really,
access to a really powerful and
useful tool, and that's
progress bars, which
I'll talk about a bit later.
But purrr is definitely kind of an
advanced programming tool.
You can go a very long
way with for loops.
But I think if you can
master the map functions with purrr,
you can write code that is more
succinct, more clear, and more
likely to be correct the
first time you write it.
So today, I'm going to
talk about purrr 1.0.
And the 1.0 release
of any package
is pretty special because
this kind of marks the package
at least, the initial
development is done.
This is a package that
we are confident about.
It's stable, and we expect it
to be around for the long-term.
And for purrr, in
particular, this
is an opportunity to take a
look at it broadly and say,
which of the functions
in this package
are really related
to the core purpose
of functional programming,
of working with vectors
and functions, and
which functions of purrr
are not and maybe need to
be superseded or duplicated.
So why don't we start with
some of my favorite features
of the purrr 1.0.
And I think the most exciting
feature or the coolest feature
is the new progress bar.
So let's just make a very
silly little example.
So let's take a brief
look at what life
is like without progress bar.
So let's just imagine we're
going to map over 100 numbers.
And in lieu of doing
anything useful here,
I'm just going to sleep this.
I'm going to pause for
a tenth of a second.
So I run this code.
I know if something
is working, I
know this is going to
take 10 seconds of total,
but I'm getting like no feedback
on what's going on.
And for a real life job,
you don't know exactly how
long it's going to
take, and you don't
know when something's
happening, like should you just
take a deep breath, should
you go grab a coffee,
or should you come
back tomorrow.
So it's great now.
In the latest version of purrr is
can say dot progress equals true
and get a convenient
progress bar that tells you
both how far through the process
you are and estimated time
to completion assuming that
every single iteration takes
about the same amount of time.
So, that alone I think is pretty
great for interactive usage.
If you are putting these inside
of a function, you can add here instead of
just a true, you
can add a string,
which will be used as a
label for the progress bar
so you know exactly
what's going on.
OK.
So my next really useful
feature inside of purrr
a big push across the tidyverse
is better error messages.
Here again, I'm just going
to make up some dumb sample
data I've just taken.
The numbers between and
one in 500 and randomly
reorganized them.
And I'm going to
make a little function.
And this function is
most of the time
it's just going to
double that number,
but every now and then that's
going to have an arrow.
Again, I'm just kind of simulating what
might happen in your real code,
not particularly useful.
But now if I run this
code, what's really handy
is map is going to
tell you exactly
where that error occurred.
So I can look at
the 318 argument,
and I know that's 123 which
by inspection of this function
is pretty easy to determine.
But in real life this is really
helpful in like figuring out exactly
where that problem occurred.
Now, of course,
you can still use
all of the useful
functions in purr safely.
And possibly if
you expect errors,
you want to capture them
some way but this new ability
to tell you where the
error occurred, is hopefully
something that's helpful
and just make your life
a little bit easier every day.
We've also generally like
just reviewed
the error messages elsewhere.
Again, purrr has big
tidyverse effort
to make sure you get
better error messages.
Is it somewhere I can
show that to you here?
So maybe if I try and supply
an environment or something
weird instead of a function.
Now we have this pretty
standard kind of error framing
where we try and tell
you what went wrong,
it was an environment, what
did we want a function.
And you'll see
this more and more
as we work on improving error
messages across the tidyverse.
We also have a new map
function called map_vec.
So if you're an
existing purrr user,
you probably know
about map_lgl produces
a logical vector, map_int
for integer vectors,
map_dbl for double vectors,
map_chr for character vectors.
You might wonder like, what
about all the other things.
Is there going to be a map_date?
Is there going to
be a map_factor?
be some kind of map
thing for every single
possible type of object in R?
This is something
we've been struggling
with for a while in purrr.
We can never quite
figure out what to do.
But there's now a new
function called map_vec
that's going to work with
any type of vector object,
so anything like a factor
or a date or a date time
is now going to work.
So for example, I could
map over the numbers 1 to 3
in my function.
I'm just going to add
those to today's date.
That's going to give
me another date,
and that's going to give
me a vector of dates.
Or I could take some letters,
first three letters, for the l,
turn that into a factor.
And then when I use map_vec,
it's going to give me a factor,
just as you expect.
So it uses the rules
from the vctrs package.
vctrs is a package
that hopefully
you as a data scientist
don't need to care about.
But it's something that
we're using more and more
in the depths of the tidyverse
to make sure all of the rules
that we use are consistent.
So you don't have to
memorize these rules.
But hopefully, as you use
functions around the tidyverse,
you just naturally over time
learn what those rules are.
You might not be able
to make them explicit
but because everything
is consistent and behaves
in the same way, you build
up this internal knowledge
of the theory that
underlies these functions.
Now one thing I should
note about map_vec
is one of its invariants,
one of its things
that always true is that
the length of the input
is the same of the
length of the output.
So if we try and create a new
vector, maybe I want to try
and just double every element,
that's not going to work.
And again, I'm going to get this
error message telling me what
is supposed to happen.
Every element has
to be size one.
And in this case, I've got
an element that's size two.
So what happens if you do want
to do something like this?
Well, you can do this with map.
That's going to give you a list
with each of those components.
And new in this version of
purrr are a set of functions
but list_c, list_rbind,
and list_cbind,
which lets you take
the output of functions
like this and for
example, combine them all into a vector.
Again, this is using
vctrs under the hood,
so this is going to give
you exactly the same.
It's going to use
exactly the same coercion
rules that map_vec uses.
But in this case, you can
use it to produce something
where every element
is a different thing.
So for example, we
could take the element
and repeat it the
number of times.
So we'll get 1 1,
2 2, and 3 3's.
If we just map that, we can
see a list with those elements.
And then if we use list_c that's
going to concatenate them all
and goes into a single vector.
So list_rbind and
list_cbind works similarly,
except for data frames.
These kind of replace, these sort of supersede
map_dfr and map_dfc.
These functions
are super useful.
We know lots of people use
them, but they're not really
map functions because of
this idea of this invariant
that the input should be the
same length as the output
for a map function.
That is pretty important
for the meaning of this map.
And so we've decided these
functions aren't really
that great.
We've superseded them.
So if you're not familiar
with what that means,
that means they
are not going away.
They're not deprecated.
They're not on a path
to being removed.
But we don't recommend
them anymore.
So in some sense these functions
are like the safest functions
to use because we're going
to just put them away
and we're never
going to touch them.
But we just don't
recommend using them.
So instead we recommend
combining a map
with one of these list
concatenation functions
where there's list_cbind,
list_rbind, or list_c.
So another area of purrr
that's got quite a lot of love
in this release is
this general idea
of flattening and
simplification.
So this is about like what
happens if you've
got some complicated
nested list and you
want to simplify things.
And things have changed.
Since we wrote this stuff in
purrr, quite a lot of things
have changed, in particular
for example tidyr now has
some really nice tools like
unnest_longer and unnest_wider
so that if you are working with
a very hierarchical data set,
you've got something
from adjacent API
and you want to turn
it into a data frame,
these tidyr functions are
really the place to start now.
Previously, you had to use these
quite low level purrr functions.
You can still keep using those.
But generally, unnest_longer
and unnest_wider
are going to allow
you to express
what you want a little bit more
simply and a little more clearly.
But this gave us an opportunity
to look at these functions
in purrr and think now,
you're not being
forced to use them
for these data science
operations, the analysis
operations.
Now we can kind of think about what
are the right primitives here.
These are things you're probably
not going to use as much day
to day.
They're more useful
when you're programming.
They might be tools
that we're going
to use elsewhere in the
tidyverse for solving problems.
But we wanted to take a
look holistically and think
what's going on.
And certainly, we cause a
lot of confusion in our team.
We couldn't remember
what does flatten
do, what does simplify do?
We've had some internal
functions and other packages
which do other things
and we just ended up
causing a lot of confusion.
We didn't have a shared
language that we could
use in talking to one another.
So we tried to unify
things, simplify things
in this version.
And just to give
you one example,
let's talk about the
flattening function.
So here I have a list.
The first element of the
list is just a number.
The second element of a
list is itself another list,
and the second element of
that list is another list.
So we have this complicated
tree-like structure.
Now what we can do
is use list_flatten
to remove one layer
of that hierarchy.
So let's just call it.
I'm going to use
str, again, just
to illustrate the
structure a little bit more
easily and then
see what happens.
So just give a little bit
more room in the console,
so we can compare them.
Previously, we had
a list two things.
Now we've got a
list of four things.
You can kind of see what's happened.
This list, the sub
list of three items
is being pulled up
to the top level.
So that list itself
had another list on it,
so we could call a list_flatten
again to flatten that.
And now we have like a, what we call
a perfectly flat list, a list
that doesn't contain
any other lists.
And if we call
list_flatten on that again,
nothing's going to happen.
We're still going to get a list.
So the list_flatten is always
going to return a list.
You don't know how long
that list is going to be.
It's going to be the sum.
It's normally going to
increase in size because you're
going to have sub lists of
varying number of children
that are going to get
hoisted up into the parent.
But you have made this
list as flat as possible.
Now if you want to
make this simpler,
you can't make this
list any flatter,
but we could use a
simpler data structure.
If we call
list_simplify now, we're
going to go to a simpler data
structure, which in this case
is a numeric vector.
So let's just illustrate the
difference between flattening
and simplification
with a list that
has a variety of types on that.
So the same structure
as before, but now
we've got a logical in there
and a character vector.
Let's flatten it.
Look at the results.
So we've still got a list.
We'll flatten that again.
We still have a list.
Now can we make
this any simpler?
Well, what happens if
we call list_simplify?
Well, no, we can't make this
any simpler because we're
trying to combine a double
and a character, a number
and a string
together, and there's
nothing simpler than
a list that will
allow you to have both of these
in a single data structure.
So this is as simple as we get.
In this idea, now we've
got this clear distinction
between flattening, which
is decreasing always.
When you flatten a list,
you still get a list,
but the number of items
might have changed.
And simplification,
we're going to always get
something that's atomic
vector, or a factor, or a date.
But you're always going to have
the same number of items in it.
I think it has
this nice symmetry,
either you're changing the size
but keeping the type the same
or you're changing the type
and keeping the size the same.
And that is a nice
split that hopefully
allows you to solve problems
without getting confused
between what
different function do.
So to finish up, I wanted
to cover what's possibly
the biggest set of changes to
purrr in this release, which
is basically saying
these are all the things
that purrr no longer does,
that we don't believe
that these are actually related
to the core purpose of purr.
And I think this is a really
important part of the lifecycle
of packages, that
as we understand
what the core purpose of
the package is better,
we can remove things.
And that comes at a cost.
If you're an existing
user, you might
love some of these functions.
That refinement
hurts existing users,
but we do it for
the future users
because when people in
the future come to purrr,
they're going to see a
more tighter, more cohesive
set of functions that
are easier to understand.
So most of these,
we have superseded.
There are some things that we've
deprecated because we think
they're pretty
uncommon to use them
or there's some major
problems with them.
So again, most of these
will continue to work.
Superseded functions will
stay around for a long time.
Deprecated functions are
definitely on the path out,
but we're trying to do that
as gradually as possible.
So if you use a deprecated
function and in the first release
it's deprecated, it'll
warn you like every 8 hours
that that function's going away.
We're trying to walk this line
between being annoying enough
that you eventually get rid
of the deprecated function
in favor of the new
solution, but not so annoying
that it's as bad as just
taking the function away.
So deprecated functions
in this release,
they will warn every 8 hours.
In the next bigger release,
which should be in 1 or 2 years,
they'll warn every
single time you use them.
And then some release
after that, probably
two or three years
after that, they
will error when you use them.
So deprecated function, you've
still got a couple of years
to fix it, but
you really do need
to work on that at some point
because those functions are
their way out.
So let's do a quick overview
though of those functions.
I'm just looking
at the news file,
which tracks every single change
you've made to the package.
If you're a really
big user of a package,
I think it's a really good
idea to familiarize yourself
with these files because
in the blog post,
we try and just hit the biggest
point, the things that we think
are most important, but useful
for you to scan the newest
functions because things
that might be important
for you might not be important
for lots of other people,
or we might just be wrong.
Also great, like if you've
got your own blog
and want to find something
to write about, read
through the news of packages and
look at stuff that we haven't
advertised because
I can guarantee you,
there are useful blog posts to be written about things
that we've changed that we're
not going to be writing about.
And that's a great way to
dig into the development
of a package and help
educate others as well.
So quick summary,
cross, I think,
it was a pretty old function.
And I think many
people are using it,
but you're much better off using
tidyr's expand_grid function.
We had a bunch of functions that
used non-standard evaluation
in some way.
There was these just
three functions in purrr
that use non-standard
evaluation or tidy
evaluation in some way which
just felt like not a good fit.
So we've got rid of those.
And no function in purrr uses,
or no non-deprecated function
in purrr uses
tidy_select anymore.
We have the lift family
of functions, which
I think are a really cool idea.
They're sort of a little
bit mind blowing
about what you can do with
functions and functional
programming.
But it's just an unusual
style of programming.
And we think that most
people are better
off not knowing about it.
Then we have a bunch of
functions that I'm like,
I have no idea why
we ever included
these in purrr, especially these
random number generators ones.
I'm not sure why they
ever ended up in purrr.
But they're now on the way out.
And splice, which is yet
a much older tool that
allows you to kind of cram
together like lists of lists.
We used to use it as kind of
an alternative for some
of the stuff that we've
replaced with dynamic dots
or tidy-select.
Those just doesn't
make any sense.
Other stuff in
maps, so things you
could do with map
functions, but again, I
don't know why we
ever implemented these
because they're not
really vectors so they
don't work anymore.
We got rid of the raw variants.
I don't think anyone
ever actually used them.
We've made some changes to
how things like map character
works.
Previously, you could just
do something like this.
And that would give
you a character vector.
Now it's going to warn.
And the reason we warn is
because the way it does
the coercion is pretty weird.
And I think this--
I don't know if I can.
It's pretty weird.
So if you're creating
really small numbers,
it just like silently
truncates them,
which is clearly pretty bad.
So we got rid of that.
There are bunch of other
deprecated functions.
The previous releases are
matching along the process
to going away altogether,
so a couple of functions.
Here is two functions
that have gone away now
that we deprecated
five years ago.
Now we can finally
get rid of them.
I think those are the main ones.
I think part of the really
important part of the process
of package lifecycle
and package development
is not just adding
new functions,
but it is equally important
to remove those functions.
And we know that removing
functions that used to work
is frustrating.
And so we have developed this
process, this lifecycle process
of deprecation where it starts
with pretty mild warnings
and gets progressively
aggressive, more
and more aggressive over time.
We hope this is useful.
We hope that this
gradually pushes
you towards the golden
path without forcing you rudely
when you're working
on something else
to urgently switch something.
But at the same time,
we believe that we want
these functions to be better.
We want these things to
have a more consistent,
cohesive syntax
because that makes
it easier for future users.
And I think we're
doing pretty well.
We've certainly
got a lot better,
I think, at handling
deprecation and breakages,
but we're certainly still
trying, still learning.
And if you have any
feedback, please let us know.
If you're interested in
learning more about functional
programming in general, I think
a really good place to start
is Advanced R, which
is three chapters
on functional
programming, functionals,
function factories,
and function operators.
And there's a lot of
text here, but you
don't have to
necessarily read the text
because I think it's got some
really good pictures as well.
And this is kind of the basic idea
of a map function.
You take a map.
The first argument is a vector,
and you've got a function.
And what that gives
you is a vector
in the result
where you've called
if on each element
of the vector in turn.
And once you've got that
idea, then we can scroll down.
And what happens if you
have like a list of elements
or going a little bit further,
what happens if you supply
additional arguments or
what happens if you have
multiple vectors that you want
to iterate through or iterate
on parallel?
I think these pictures give
you a really quick overview
of what does map2 do.
Well, map2 is two
vectors, and it
calls if on the first
element of the first one,
and the first element
of the second one, then
the second element of
this one, and so on.
And then once you've
internalized what map2 does,
you might wonder, well, what
happens if it got three vectors
or I care about the output?
And I think if you just
skim through these pictures,
then we can get into
the reduce family
and other more complicated
things, this can give you
a great sense of the basic
idea of these functions.
So in this video, I've given you, the top highlights, my top highlights, of purrr 1.0.
If you want to learn
more, read the blog post.
If you want more
details than that,
I'd recommend reading the news
file as I mentioned earlier.
If you are using a
deprecated function
or a superseded
function and want
to learn what you
should do now, I
forgot to mention this
earlier, but if you
go to the documentation
for that function
and scroll down to
the examples, you'll
see that there's a
bunch of examples
that show you what
did you do previously
and what you should do now.
So hopefully, that will guide
you in updating your code too.
If you've got other problems, if
we have broken something that's
really important to
you, a great place to go
is the GitHub page for purr,
log your issues, log questions.
If you do have a
problem with your code,
really, really useful for
us if you create a reprex
or reproducible example.
Of course, we have a
package to help you do that.
So you might want to
learn a little bit
about using reprexes.
This just gives us
some runnable code
that we can immediately run.
There's no trying to figure
out exactly what you did.
We can take your code, see
what you did, run it ourselves.
And that just makes answering
your question that much easier.
If you have something
that doesn't
rise quite to the level of
a bug or a GitHub issue,
another great place to
reach me is on Mastodon.
I'm very happy to answer
any general questions there.
I'll point you in the
right direction to places
in the docs.
So I hope you've enjoyed
learning more about purrr,
and thanks for
watching this video.
[MUSIC PLAYING]